hallo leute wir sind heute mal auf die
straße gegangen um für euch ein neues
video aufzunehmen
wie ihr wisst haben viele geschäfte in
deutschland und auch in anderen ländern
im moment geschlossen und wir wollen das
zum anlass nehmen um mit euch mal über
das thema öffnungszeiten zu reden
das manchmal gar nicht so einfach ist
das geschäft geöffnet oder hat das
geschäft geöffnet
wir werden jetzt mal einen kleinen
spaziergang hier durch die nachbarschaft
machen und mit euch über das vokabular
reden los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese pizzeria ist gerade geschlossen
dieser späte hat normalerweise jeden tag
bis mitternacht geöffnet
im moment ist das geschäft mit dem namen
depot jedoch wegen corona geschlossen
diese bäckerei ist geöffnet
lebensmittelgeschäfte also geschäfte in
denen man lebensmittel essen kaufen kann
dürfen noch auf haben so zum beispiel
auch bäckereien
man darf jedoch nur etwas zum mit
rausnehmen kaufen und sich nicht
hinsetzen dieses geschäft hinter mir hat
gerade sonderöffnungszeiten es ist im
moment von 9 bis 17 uhr geöffnet
diese bar ist auch geschlossen
dieses café hat auch zu der gemüse kebab
hat geöffnet
man darf jedoch nur dinge zum mitnehmen
kaufen und man muss 1,5 meter abstand
halten
der bürgerladen hat vorübergehend
geschlossen
auch dieses café ist zu dieses geschäft
hat normalerweise von 9 bis 20 uhr
geöffnet
jetzt zeige ich euch wie man fragt ob
ein geschäft geöffnet ist
weißt du wann all die aufmacht ich
glaube all die macht um 7 auf weißt du
ob edeka noch auf hat nein edeka hat
schon zu
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man in einem
geschäft fragt ob das geschäft noch
geöffnet ist
haben sie noch geöffnet ja wir haben
geöffnet haben sie noch aus nein wir
haben leider schon geschlossen
entschuldigung haben sie schon zu
leider schließen wir jetzt dieser
plattenladen ist von montags bis
freitags zwischen 13 und 19 uhr geöffnet
und samstags ist er auch zwischen 12 und
18 uhr geöffnet
aus irgendeinem grund hat die
buchhandlung hinter mir noch geöffnet
dieser copy shop ist geschlossen
etwas was für viele verwirrend ist ist
ob man das hilfswerk haben oder sein
benutzt ist das geschäft geöffnet
oder hat das geschäft geöffnet ist der
laden auf oder hat der laden auf und die
antwort ist ganz einfach dieses mal
man kann beides benutzen denn es hängt
tatsächlich davon ab aus welcher
perspektive man das betrachtet
aus der perspektive des geschäfts hat
das geschäft geöffnet
aus der perspektive des außenstehenden
ist das geschäft geöffnet
aber in der umgangssprache benutzt man
einfach beides austauschbar ich sage das
geschäft ist zu das geschäft hat zu das
geht beides das war unser kurzes video
über öffnungszeiten wenn ihr noch fragen
habt schreibt von zwitter einen
kommentar und wenn ihr weiter euer
deutsch verbessern wollt dann empfehlen
wir euch dass ihr mal unsere app sie
länger ausprobiert
dort könnt ihr viele sachen machen zum
beispiel vokabeln lernen einen gender
trainer benutzen und das wichtigste ist
ihr könnt auch eure eigene aussprache
üben
nämlich indem ihr eure eigene stimme
aufnimmt und sie abspielt unter eure
eigene stimme und eure eigene aussprache
mit der aussprache eines muttersprachler
es vergleicht dadurch lernt ihr immer
selbstbewusster zu werden beim sprechen
probiert das mal aus und wir freuen uns
wenn wir uns am sonntag wieder sehen
bis bald
[Musik]